♪ (music) ♪
Hello, everyone. Welcome back.
Welcome back.
I'm Jeremiah and this is Andrew.
We are here from the TensorFlow Hub team.
We are based in Zurich, Switzerland,
and we're excited
to share TensorFlow Hub today.
So this first slide is actually one
that I stole-- I took it from a colleague,
Noah Fidel, who leads TensorFlow Serving,
and Noah uses this slide
to tell a personal story,
and it kind of shows the growth of things,
the type of tools that we use
to do software engineering.
And it shows how they mature over time.
And he also connects this
to a similar thing happening,
the tools we use to do machine learning.
And he draws these connections.
We're rediscovering things
as we grow our machine learning tools,
things like the machine learning
equivalent of source control,
and the machine learning equivalent
of continuous integration.
And Noah also makes
this really interesting observation
that this growth
on the machine learning side
is lagging behind
the software engineering side
by 15, 20 years.
So this creates
a really interesting opportunity, right?
We can look at software engineering.
We can look at some of the things
that have happened there,
and think about what kind of impact
they may have on machine learning.
And so looking at software engineering,
there's something that's so fundamental,
it's almost easy to skip over,
and that's this idea of sharing code,
shared repositories.
On the surface, this makes us
immediately more productive.
We can search for code.
We can download it.
We can use it.
But it has these really powerful
second order effects.
This actually changes
the way we write code.
We refactor our code.
We put it in libraries.
We share those libraries,
and this really makes people
even more productive,
and it's the same dynamic
that we want to create
from machine learning
with TensorFlow Hub.
TensorFlow Hub lets you build,
share and use
pieces of machine learning.
So why is this important?
Well, anyone who's done
machine learning from scratch knows
you need a lot to do it well.
You need an algorithm; you need data.
You need compute power and expertise,
and if you're missing any of these,
you're out of luck.
So TensorFlow Hub lets you distill
all these things down
into a reusable package we call a module.
Those modules go in TensorFlow Hub
where people can discover them
and then easily use them.
So you'll notice I'm saying module
instead of model.
It turns out that a model is
a little bit too big
to really encourage sharing.
If you have a model,
you can use that model
if you have the exact inputs it wants
and you expect
the exact outputs it provides.
If there's any little differences,
you're kind of out of luck.
So modules are a smaller piece.
If you think of a model
like a binary,
think of a module like a library.
So on the inside, a module
is actually a saved model,
so this lets us package up
the algorithm in the form of a graph,
lets us package up the weights.
You can do things like initialize,
use assets.
And our libraries make it very easy
to instantiate these
in your TensorFlow code.
So you can compose these
in interesting ways.
This makes things very reusable.
You can produce one
of these and share it.
These are also retrainable.
Once you patch it in
to your bigger program,
you can back propagate
through it just like normal.
And this is really powerful
because if you do happen
to have enough data,
you can customize the TF Hub module
for your own application.
And to tell us a little bit more
about some of those applications,
I'll hand it over to Andrew.
Thanks, Jeremiah.
Let's look at a specific example
of using a TF Hub module
for image retraining.
Let's say that we're going to make an app
that can classify
rabbit breeds from photos.
The problem is we only have
a couple hundred examples,
probably not enough to train
an entire image classification model
from scratch.
But what we could do is start
from an existing general purpose
image classification model.
Most of the high performing ones
these days are trained
on millions of examples
and they can easily classify
thousands of categories.
So we want to reuse the architecture
and the trained weights of that model
without the classification layers.
And in that way, we can add
our own rabbit classifier on top,
and we can train it
on our own rabbit examples
and keep the reused weights fixed.
So since we're using TensorFlow Hub,
our first stop is tensorflow.org/hub
where we can find a list
of all the newly released state of the art
and also the well-known image modules.
Some of them include
the classification layers,
and some of them remove them
just providing a feature vector as output.
So we'll choose one of the feature
vector ones for this case.
Let's use NASNet which is
a state of the art image module
that was created
by a neural architecture search.
So you just paste the URL
of a module,
and TensorFlow Hub takes care
of downloading the graph
and all of its weights
and importing it into your model.
And in that one line, you're ready
to use the module like any function
so here we just provide
a batch of inputs,
and we get back our feature vectors.
We add a classification layer on top,
and we output our predictions.
But in that one line,
you get a huge amount of value.
In this particular case,
more than 62,000 hours of GPU time
went into finding the best architecture
for NASNet and training the result.
And all of the expertise, research,
testing, that the authors put into that--
that's all built into the module.
Plus that module can be fine-tuned
with your model,
so if you have enough examples
you can potentially get better performance
if you use a low learning rate,
if you set the trainable parameter
to true and if you use
the training version of the graph.
So NASNet is available in a large size
as well as a mobile-sized module,
and then there's also
the new progressive NASNet,
and then on a number
of new MobileNet modules
for doing on-device image classification
as well as some industry standard ones
like Inception and ResNet.
That complete list is
at tensorflow.org/hub.
And of course all those modules
are pre-trained
using the TF slim checkpoints,
and they're ready
to be used for classification
or as feature vector inputs
to your own model.
Okay, let's look at another example--
in this case, doing
a little bit of text classification.
So we'd like to know whether
a restaurant review is
a positive or negative sentiment.
So as Jeremiah mentioned,
one of the great things
about TensorFlow Hub
is that it packages
the graph with the data.
For our text and embedding modules,
that means that all
of the preprocessing is included,
doing things like normalizing
and tokenizing operations.
So we can use
a pre-trained sentence embedding module
to map a full sentence
to an embedding vector.
So if we want to classify
some restaurant reviews,
then we just take one
of those sentence embedding modules,
we add our own classification layer on top
and then we train with our reviews
while we keep
the sentence module's weights fixed.
And just like for the image modules,
tensorflow.org/hub lists a number
of different text modules.
We have neural network language models
that are trained on genus
for English, Japanese, German and Spanish.
We also have Word2vec models
trained on Wikipedia,
as well as a new module
called ELMo that models
the characteristics of word use
and how those uses vary across context.
And then there's also something
really new, as in today.
You may have seen a new paper
this morning from Ray Kurzweil's team.
This is the Universal Sentence Encoder.
It's a sentence-level embedding module.
It's trained on a variety of tasks,
and it enables a variety of tasks,
in other words, universal.
So some of the things that it's good for
are semantic similarity
doing custom text classification,
clustering and semantic search.
But the best part about it
is how little training data
is actually required
to adapt the module to your own problem.
So that sounds great
in our particular case.
Let's try it
on the restaurant review task.
So we just paste that URL from the paper,
and like before TensorFlow Hub downloads
the module and inserts it into your graph.
But this time, we're using
the text embedding column.
That way we can feed into an estimator
to do the classification part.
And just like
with the image retraining example,
this module can be fine-tuned
with your model
by setting trainable to true.
Of course, you have
to lower the learning rate
so that you don't ruin
the existing weights that are in there,
but it's something that's worth exploring
if you have enough data.
Now let's take a closer look
at that URL.
As Jeremiah mentioned,
a module is a program,
so make sure what you're executing
is from a location that you trust.
In this case, the module
is from tfhub.dev
so that's our new source
for Google-provided modules
like NASNet
and a universal sentence encoder.
Over time, we would like to create
a place where you can also publish
the modules that you create.
So in this case, Google is the publisher,
and Universal Sentence Encoder
is the name of the module.
And finally, the version number is one.
So TensorFlow Hub considers modules
to be immutable,
that way you don't have to worry
about the weights changing
between training sessions.
So that module URL
and all of the module URLs
on tfhub.dev include a version number.
And you can take that URL
and paste it into your browser
and see the complete documentation
for any module that's hosted on tfhub.dev.
Here's the particular one
for the Universal Sentence Encoder.
Then we also have modules
for other domains
besides text classification
and image retraining,
like a generative image module
that contains a progressive GAN
that was trained on [inaudible].
And we added another module
that was based
on Deep Local Features network
which can identify the key points
of landmark images.
Both of those have great Colab notebooks
that are available on tensorflow.org/hub.
In fact, the images here
were created from them.
And we're going to be adding
more modules over time
for tasks like audio and video
over the next few months.
But most importantly,
we're really excited to see
what you build with TensorFlow Hub.
Use the hashtag #tfhub
when you build notebooks
and share modules.
And visit tensorflow.org/hub
for links to our documentation,
including examples with tutorials,
interactive notebooks and code labs
and our new discussion mailing list.
So from Jeremiah, me and everyone
on our team in Zurich,
I want to thank you so much.
(applause)
♪ (music) ♪